hallo
herzlich willkommen in israel meine
zuschauer also ihr ihr habt euch von mir
kürbis rezepte gewünscht und heute werde
ich einen kürbis aus dem ofen machen und
zwar nämlich dafür einen wasser nass
kürbis und werde ihn mit gemüse film und
das ganze ist ein vegetarisches gericht
zeige ich mal die zutaten an zutaten
brauche ich einen bonus kürbissen
wasserrad eine zwiebel eine gelbe und
rote paprikaschote zwei zucchinis 200
gramm cocktailtomaten und sechs
frühlingszwiebeln vier esslöffel rapsöl
2 knoblauchzehen und hier vorne habe ich
noch rosmarin und thymian und 100 gramm
jobkrise sage ich euch später war ich
werde zuerst einmal den kürbis nehmen da
ist jetzt schon gewaschen und den werde
ich jetzt halbieren
bei dem ist es so da kann man die schale
nicht mit verzehren
aber ich werde ihn jetzt trotzdem nicht
schälen und einfach später ohne schale
verzerren zeigt zeig ich euch natürlich
wie ihn ganz vorsichtig halbieren
jetzt nehme ich die kerne heraus und mir
gefällt an dem kürbis vor allem die
tolle farbe und der kürbis heißt
butternut weile einfach puttrich und
nussig schmeckt und er wird ganz zart
also man kann es zum beispiel mit dem
auch eine suppe machen und wieder
richtig schön cremig und der kürbis ganz
schön weich
die kerne können jetzt übrigens ein
bisschen abwaschen und dann in einer
pfanne rösten und so ein bisschen
draußen
dann könnten nicht schälen und essen
oder können sie auch schon roh essen
aber dass so ein bisschen geld schicht
muss ich dazu sagen die würde ich dann
vorher erst trocknen lassen
jetzt schließt sich den kürbis zur
kreuzförmig ein grab mit einem messer
achtet einfach drauf dass sie die schale
nicht so zerstört und immer wirklich nur
ganz kurze kleine stiche macht
den kürbis streiche ich jetzt mit dem öl
ein
da kommt jetzt noch salz und pfeffer
draus dann musste er erstmal vor gegart
werden damit es später auch gut durch
ist und das gemüse später darauf
bissfest bleibt und deswegen werden
schien ist gleich 220 grad im ofen etwas
20 minuten garen
die
und in der zwischenzeit kann mich jetzt
schon um das gemüse kümmern
die tomaten reden jetzt halbiert die
knöpfe und die zwiebel werden fein
gewürfelt die zwiebel werden in ringe
geschnitten und alles andere wird in
zwei zentimeter großer würfel
geschnitten und die l nimmt die küche
auseinander
das gemüse habe ich jetzt hier in der
große schüssel gegeben
und da kommen jetzt die kräuter noch mit
rein die zöpfe ich jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen ab und habe ich jetzt auch
frische kräuter
da kommt noch das restliche öl mit dazu
das sind etwa zwei esslöffel
unkommentiert nach seinem treffer mit
rein ist nicht zu arg zusetzen du später
kommt es richtig dick aktive mit
jetzt wird es einfach nur kurz vermischt
und dann muss ich noch schnell auf den
kürbis in bakuba
jetzt ist der kürbis bereit und jetzt
fühle ich hier so ein bisschen gemüse
rhein und der rest kommt dann einfach
drum herum
und jetzt muss das gericht noch mal für
20 minuten backofen
der kürbis und des gemüses was durch
gegart und jetzt kommt auch der käse mit
dazu und ich habe mir gesagt diesen chat
käse und zweitens käse und den gibt's in
türkischen supermärkten oder auch
vereinzelt in großen deutschen
supermärkten sag ich jetzt mal und es
ist ein käse der ist geschmacklich ganz
besonderes also die konsistenz ist
zerfetzt und er ist leicht salzig und
sehr würzig und meine mama also von ihr
kenne ich das so dass sie den käse gerne
abfälschte ist gerne weniger salzig mag
ich mache allerdings genauso für mich
ist er genau perfekt denn ich werde
ihnen jetzt gleich einfach so oft gemüse
mit drauf geben und diesen käse könnte
jetzt benutzen für aufläufe zb der
könnten beim tourist mit rein geben oder
einfach ganz kalt ihnen salat und dann
solltet ihr aber das restliche essen gar
nicht mehr so selten weil er dann
einfach dieser käse die wird somit rein
bringt alle total vielseitig und ich
finde es sehr interessant denn gibt es
ebenso einer verpackung oder auch als ok
so zusammen zusammen wie sagt man da
zusammen geflochten und ja ich finde es
richtig toll und den gebe ich jetzt hier
auf das gemüse mit drauf jetzt nämlich
den käse und der kommt jetzt hier drüber
und dann muss das ganze noch mal für
zwei bis drei minuten überbacken
das gericht ist fertig und jetzt ein
bisschen abkühlen lassen
der demokrat darf gleich probieren und
er verbrennt sich ja sonst immer
deswegen habe ich gedacht komm mal zehn
minuten jetzt könnt ihr das so machen
das jetzt einfach ein bisschen raus
löffelt ist alles geschmackssache und
ich finde alles toll
bis auf kürbis habe ich ein bisschen
angst ich weiß also bei kürbis ist halt
so murat mag eigentlich keinen kürbis
und eigentlich mag auch nicht soviel
vegetarisch aber ich glaube dass ich mit
dem käse bei dir so ein bisschen was
raushauen kann denn da schmeckt würzig
und bringt da richtig geschmack mit rein
also man kann den käse natürlich auch
ein bisschen vorher mit zum kürbis geben
dann wird er einfach nur weiter sehr
heiß und verläuft so ein bisschen aber
ich hab das jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen nur anderem wollten wie ein
kind müsse also eine kürbissuppe lieber
wirklich cool der mir gefallen ja vom
letzten jahr
die ist ja auch sehr lecker ich habe mit
dem button hat auch gut machen einfach
ein bisschen raus löffeln und da merkt
man auch schon wie schön weil ich das
einfach geworden ist hieraus noch
bisschen gemüse ich gespannt
also ist es halt alles geschmackssache
ich mein muss ich mir erst mal sagen die
mag ich nicht gesehen hat lass dich
überraschen
also für mich dass ich von meinen kann
ich von meinen rezept granit gemüse karl
gabl haben rosen rezepte sind immer am
liebsten weil man kein land alles
vorbereiten und dann einfach in den ofen
schieben und in der zeiträume schon
immer die küche auf und richtete den
tisch und so weiter und habe dann
einfach alles gleichzeitig fertig und
was sagst du dazu
so schmeckt wie kartoffeln ja
also bat speck bisschen bittrich und
lustig weiter nahrung und super oder
und dann bist du jetzt fleisch muss ich
kein fleisch also die sich auch ein
sättigendes rezept also das reicht
locker für vier personen
auch als hauptmahlzeit da brauche ich
gar nicht so viel davon essen wird papst
hat und vor allem mag ich die
kombination mit dem kürbis dem käse und
dann noch den verschiedenen gemüse und
ihr könnt ihr wirklich am gemüse nehmen
was ihr möchtet wenn die champignons tat
nimmt die champignons auberginen alles
was ihr gerne mögt es gut ein bisschen
mehr käse vielleicht ja ich habe da ein
bisschen aufgehoben dann kann ja noch
kalt mittels dazu geben um den käse
könnte übrigens auch komplett kalt mit
dazu geben also gar nicht in den ofen
geben dann gibt es mit oben drauf da
schmeckt auch übrigens im salat wirklich
sehr hervorragend und warten das freut
mich vor kürbis naja aber jedesmal
zeigst du hast ja nicht schmeckt ja mit
super dass ich jetzt weitere kürbis
rezept zu machen
das freut mich also was ihr jetzt auch
lust bekommen hat auf dieses rezept geht
auch sallys - blog.de da steht noch mal
alles ganz genau für euch und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim nachmachen
wir wünschen guten appetit du kannst
aber auch gerne warten bis wir zum essen
ins rheinland
er sagte wenn es noch heimat oder
pastinaken so klein entscheiden
in würfel geschnitten das auch noch mit
drei macht mit noch besser schmecken
jetzt macht natürlich allem ein
vegetarisches um einen vegetarischen
rezept wieder kaputt aber also viel spaß
beim nachkochen und wir sehen uns das
nächste mal bis dahin tschüss echt super
ich wollte nur käse